alright hey everybody sorry for the
technical issues so I'm pretty sure this
will get sorted out a lot more smoothly
from now on so welcome to ME 564
mechanical engineering analysis I'm
Steve Brenton I'm going to be the
instructor for this class I want to
start off by just saying I'm really
excited to be teaching this class this
is some of my favorite material and I
really want to make this fun and
interesting for everybody I know that
this is going to have some elements that
are review for a lot of you but pretty
quickly we're going to get into new
material I hope that most of you haven't
seen and that you'll find really really
useful ok so I wanted to just go through
the syllabus briefly introduce myself in
my TAS
tell you a little bit about the
expectations for this class and then
we'll actually just start talking about
some of the material ok so you can
always find a material at the course
website I'm just using my faculty
homepage you know faculty dot washington
CD u tilde oh really oh please come over
yeah come on over ok and /m e 564 so
right now all that you're going to find
there is a PDF syllabus but in the
future I'll actually have a website with
links to the homeworks links to the
exams and all upload every single page
of my course notes and code that I write
in class ok so you'll have everything ok
so usually people want to know about
grading this is kind of the most
pressing matter ok so I'm going to have
two exams a midterm and a final and then
I'm going to have about five homeworks
so I think I think five homeworks is
about enough sometimes it'll be every
other week sometimes they'll be
back-to-back from week to week and here
are the dates normally I don't have my
exams waited quite so
heavily but this class is come on in
this class is going to be on your
qualifying exam so I'm going to be
writing the calls this year and next
year and so I want to give you a little
bit of practice so you're going to get
my exams they're worth quite a lot
because I really want you two to prepare
for them come on in everyone okay ok any
questions about exams or homeworks maybe
we'll just wait until everyone comes in
okay does everyone have a seat yeah okay
good so for those of you who came in
late you can find the course website
here it's my website faculty Washington
edu slash tilde Brunton ME 564 okay you
can find this PDF syllabus and soon
there will be links to everything
lectures lecture notes codes homeworks
everything will be on this website
there's a midterm and a final exam
they're both take-home exams so I think
I'll hand one of them out on Monday and
it'll be due on Wednesday two days later
the next one will be handed out on
Wednesday and it'll be doing class on
Friday okay so you'll have I think as
much time as you want to to work on them
but the exam should take between two and
four hours okay so for those of you who
came in late first of all sorry that it
told you to go to a different room and
second of all I'm going to be writing
the qualifying exam for this year and
next year in math so these exams are
going to be kind of practice for that so
that's why I have them worth a lot of
the grade and the final exam is
cumulative okay
ok any questions about grading or
homeworks or exams nope okay cool all
right so I'm Steve Brunton you'll be
able to find me in the mechanical
engineering building in room 305 I'm
going to have office hours every week
directly after this Wednesday class so
from 10:30 to 11:30 a.m. and you can
also set up times for appointments okay
so I have pretty flexible
end-of-the-week Thursdays and Fridays
Mondays and Tuesdays I'm almost
completely booked unless you want to
come in at 6 a.m. okay
but I'll always have this one our office
hours and you can always schedule things
with me by email later in the week okay
and you can find my email and phone
number so my teaching assistants Rihanna
and Scott are you guys both here okay
they're in the back saying hi so they're
going to have office
our something between two and three
office hours each every week and we're
going to have these probably you know
Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday
because homeworks are going to be due on
Fridays and they're going to figure out
the exact schedule and get back to us
really soon okay so this document is
going to change a little bit over the
next probably two or three days and if
you all have any questions about
anything at any time please you know
feel free to interrupt so once we really
start diving into material a lot of this
class is going to be discussion oriented
so I really want to get questions and
ideas from you so I'll give you a little
bit about my philosophy I'm going to be
teaching you what I think are some of
the most powerful tools in analysis for
engineering systems so we're going to
learn Oh des linear algebra complex
analysis PDEs all kinds of great stuff
but I really really want to focus on
applications okay so I have tons of
applications that are near and dear to
my heart so for a lot of my life I've
worked on unsteady fluid dynamics for
mixing enhancement turbulence control
aerodynamic performance improvements on
small scale aircraft recently I've
started working a lot on disease
modeling and neuroscience and so we're
going to have a whole range of
applications weather and climate systems
some applications and control space
mission design and if you have anything
that you find really interesting that I
would like to to kind of build that into
this class also okay so part of my
philosophy in engineering analysis I
want you to be able to do things by hand
right we're going to learn about Fourier
integrals and how to solve PD ES and OD
es and all of this by hand but I think
equally important is that you know how
to implement these in a computer right
this is the age of computers we all have
like I carry a computer around in my
pocket that's faster than the first cray
okay this is kind of amazing and so I
really want us to be thinking about how
we can implement these tools and
computers and so
my language of choice is MATLAB just a
quick poll of hands how many of you have
used in that lab or currently using that
lab how many don't okay so if you don't
know MATLAB I think that that's totally
fine it's not like a super central part
of this but I would recommend you know
downloading a copy or going to one of
the computer labs and just getting
familiar with it again okay because I am
going to be doing a lot of examples in
MATLAB there's a student edition of
MATLAB you can buy for I think a hundred
bucks or your advisor can buy it for you
for a hundred bucks I would recommend it
I think you're probably all going to use
it a lot for the next however many years
there's also a MATLAB laboratory in the
ICL building so bo2 too and bo27 of this
building there's a bunch of MATLAB
terminal so you can log on for free and
you can also secure shell in from your
laptops or home computers okay questions
about computing or any of that okay
the textbook is engineering advanced
engineering mathematics by cry sig the
10th edition how many of you have this
book ok so a lot of you have it how many
of you felt that it was overpriced and
too heavy I think it's a little
overpriced and it's way too
it's like 1,200 pages let me just see if
I have it still ok yeah so this is the
book I don't carry a copy around I think
it's ridiculous I'm going to try to move
away from this book in the next two
years so for right now we're probably
kind of stuck using parts of this book
so you can use it as a reference we're
going to use it for some homework
problems I'm I haven't opened the book
yet like except for about 2 minutes and
so I'm really going to spend most of the
time doing material from my own lecture
notes all of the videos are going to be
online so this class is recorded you'll
all have access to the videos on canvas
I'll upload all of my notes we're going
to use this for reference and for the
homeworks but if you don't feel like
buying it and you want to scan the
homework pages out from a friend that's
totally fine with me
if you want a good reference book for
the future you know I have a copy on my
bookshelf
you could you
for that so that's all I'm going to say
about that yeah I think you should well
okay if you want to use it as a
reference I think using a previous
edition would be fine but I'm going to
assign some homework problems out of the
tenth edition and so that's the key
thing every year there's a few people
that solve the homework problems for the
eighth of the ninth edition and all of
the problems are going to be from the
tenth edition
okay but hopefully someone has a copy of
the tenth edition that they're willing
to kind of share and make available okay
I think it's like 250 bucks
I didn't know books for that expensive
seems really expensive so I didn't buy a
copy anyone any other questions about
the book yeah I did a quick search on
google or shell Theo Cambridge points
this out for free on PDF they do yeah
Cambridge chess it was some something
like Cambridge
okay so I found it from an Iranian
website but I bet you can find it
somewhere I'm not recommending that you
do that I think that would be
technically illegal the I think that
they would be upset if no one bought any
books so maybe you can pool and buy
three or four bucks okay so that's the
book it is a pretty good reference okay
I don't want to like I don't want to
downplay the book too much it is a good
book it has almost everything two
hundred and fifty dollars is a lot of
money okay so this is the canvas website
where you can you all have access to the
videos okay so this video will be online
shortly I think it's probably streaming
actually so it's canvas uwd you slash
courses and the number is nine one seven
five three eight so nine one seven five
three eight slash users and I'll put
this link up on my website okay so once
I have the course website on my page
you'll have this link forever okay good
see if there's anything else yeah I'm
sorry I don't know if you can access
these videos after the quarter so I've
done this flipped version before where
we had video lectures and so what I do
is I use Firefox and I downloaded this
plug-in called download flash and video
and so when the videos are actually
playing in canvas you can just download
the flash video to your hard drive it's
going to fill up your hard drive
unfortunately I think there about a
gigabyte every lecture okay okay so
we're using MATLAB we have a textbook
that's pretty extensive now I'm going to
tell you about the syllabus okay so this
is a really rough syllabus right now I
have a pretty good idea of the first
part but I'm still developing the next
part so this is the first time I've
taught this class and I really want to
kind of get a feel for what everyone's
mathematical comfort level is and how
far and how fast we can go but the basic
kind of main idea is that we're going to
build up to solving really complicated
Oh des interesting so Oh des are the
basis of how we model physical systems
that change in time okay so we're going
to build up to doing ordinary
differential equations some pretty neat
stuff so we're going to do nonlinear
systems high dimensional systems we're
going to look at chaos and the numerical
integration of OU des and vector fields
we're going to get into some numerical
calculus and to do that we're going to
build on foundations in linear algebra
so how do you solve large systems of
equations you know by hand and in MATLAB
how do you do eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and use those for stability
analysis so we're going to look at
controls problems and fluids problems
and all kinds of neat engineering
applications so usually when I teach
kind of the more applied math version of
this class I say that I don't require
any physics knowledge you know it's I'll
write down the equations and you can
take them for granted but I think since
all of you have
great mechanical backgrounds it'll be
really nice to have some motivating
physical examples you know to study
these problems so I'll also include some
vector calculus just you know as I
review mostly but some of the some of
the highlights of vector calculus and
I'll focus on numerical aspects also
what I really want to do this year in
five sixty four and five sixty five
which is next quarter is also start to
introduce some more modern concepts like
data analytics okay so all of us are
going to have mountains of data that's
never going to change from now on you're
going to be dealing with a mountain of
data if you want to if you want to
you'll have access to mountains of data
and so I want to show you how we can
integrate some of the new techniques in
dimensionality reduction for large scale
systems machine learning visualization
for engineering systems okay and you
know this will be kind of a topical
overview but it'll give you the roadmap
so you can know where to go and look you
know when you're actually doing research
problems and that's my real goal I want
to develop your knowledge so that you
can excel in your research in mechanical
engineering okay that's my number one
goal that's this is my favorite thing to
do I love teaching this is you know my
number one priority this term so I hope
you all you know really get a lot out of
this I want to know so almost everyone
has had linear algebra is that right
anyone not have linear algebra or Odie's
okay so I know that some of you you know
it might have been a long time and so
we're going to start from the basics
we're going to start from the ground
level but we're going to build up pretty
quickly okay okay good any questions
about the syllabus remember it's really
rough
oh sure okay okay good so I'm going to
go I want to give you some motivating
examples okay I want to tell you some of
the things that I like to study and some
of the things that we're going to bring
into this class and then if we have time
I might work out kind of a simple
problem in that lab and then on Friday
we're really going to hit the ground
running with Odie's okay all right let's
see if I can okay can everyone see this
yeah okay so like I told you I work a
lot in unsteady fluid dynamics this is a
simulation of fluid flow past a
two-dimensional wing this is a really
tie model simulation for for example
this could model the flow past a small
insect wing like a mosquito or a fruit
fly and the u-dub actually has great
resources in the biology department some
of the best people in the world that do
insect flights are at u-dub and so this
is a really dear problem that I've been
working on for a long time what's kind
of interesting about this we could write
down the equations of motion for a fluid
as a partial differential equation so
we'll you know learn how to solve PDE s
and analyze them in the next quarter of
this class or what we could do is we
could take our computational domain and
break it up into a million boxes and
turn this PDE into a million dimensional
ordinary differential equation might be
nonlinear it might be really nasty but
that's pretty much how we solve all
problems in computational physics now is
that we discretize them somehow we kind
of project our PDE
onto a million discrete little boxes and
then we solve that ordinary differential
equation okay so this is just one of the
perspectives we're going to take in this
class is that almost everything in the
world is a big ordinary differential
equation okay these are just some other
cool movies of you know plates wings
moving up and down we're going to build
the tools to understand things like the
Navy your Stokes equations
elastic equations and all kinds of other
fundamental physical laws that you're
going to be using in your other
qualifying exams I've used these methods
computationally a lot to study fluid
mixing so here's what you would have if
you have a big you know steel plate in a
bathtub or in a swimming pool and you
start plunging it up and down and if you
put some dye near the plate these are
the mixing patterns that you would get
in that fluid so this computation used
to have to run on a supercomputer with
about 50 cores and using some of the
methods we're going to talk about in
this class we were able to speed it up
so it runs almost in real time on a
laptop which is kind of nice so we're
going to learn about how to integrate
particles through unsteady vector fields
so if you think of a little plankton or
a little piece of food in the water it
moves along based on the fluid velocity
field which is spatially varying it
varies in time it's really complicated
maybe turbulent and so we're going to
analyze how to integrate those particles
and understand things like how a
jellyfish both feeds and propels itself
at the same time so I'll just show you
this again so these blue particles get
ejected into the wake of this jellyfish
to produce kind of momentum that pushes
it forward while the green particles get
entrained into its feeding chamber so in
one stroke or a series of strokes the
jellyfish both feeds and eat and propels
itself and by using some of these
analyses these ordinary differential
equation analyses people have actually
been able to make artificial jellyfish
so this is rat heart tissue grafted onto
a little mold with eight pacemakers and
so if they put this in you know an
electrolyte solution they can pulse it
and actually have these pacemakers fire
and and this little synthetic jellyfish
starts to swim
so this is really a great progression
from theoretical developments of how to
model a PDE to simulations in a no de to
actual engineering design that's truly
bio-inspired
this is one of my favorite examples this
happened I think about two years yeah
two years ago but it took a lot of
iterations the first the first few of
these didn't didn't go so well so time
varying vector fields are also really
really important to understanding
climate and weather and pollution and
disease spread so here we're looking at
the Gulf oil spill pop propagating
through the Gulf of Mexico
again this is an unsteady highly complex
you know multi-resolution problem
there's tons of scales in space and time
it's time varying but we can solve this
as a numerical ordinary differential
equation using data right we collect
data from satellites we can build a
model we can predict where oil goes and
a few years ago someone actually use
this analysis to find all of the
coherent structures and patterns across
the entire globe so these are I think
based on particle integrations so they
dropped little virtual buoys and
integrated them for I think 200 days
forward in time and this tells them
where all of the dominant eddies in the
ocean currents are across the entire
world this is another example of a
supercomputer computation that we can
now do on our laptops and this was only
four years ago so it's kind of
remarkable how fast things are moving
now okay
I also really care a lot about pollution
unfortunately a lot of the cool tools
developed in math have been to study
where to dump pollution more effectively
so that it doesn't mix up in places
where we live we're also going to use
the solar system and space dynamics as
an example of a complex ordinary
differential equation okay so if you
write down Newton's laws for you know
let's say eight and a half planets and a
Sun
then you get a really complicated
nonlinear chaotic dynamical system and
some of the tools we're going to to
learn in this class are going to help us
for example build efficient space
missions if you wanted to go from Earth
to Jupiter and then spend time around
each of its moons to design a science
mission okay so that's one of the
applications of what we can do so this
is kind of a controls application
another one is this is kind of neat I
wish the said Blue Origin but they don't
release videos of their tests so this is
stabilizing an inverted pendulum it's a
really fancy expensive inverted pendulum
but really at the end of the day this is
an inverted pendulum controller okay so
you have this nonlinear differential
equation for an inverted pendulum and if
you use a small angle approximation so
if your controls good then it stays
pretty much vertical you can linearize
your differential equation and you can
build a control law to stabilize it okay
so this is another example we're going
to to do in this class pretty remarkable
so they actually developed the
controller for the lunar lander really
at the dawn of computer control and this
is a much harder problem because they
couldn't throttle their thrusters they
just had to turn them on or off so they
had to use what's called bangbang
control so they would bang bang their
thrusters and try to land this tin can
on the moon much much easier now okay
and then the last example I'll talk
about our disease networks so some of us
might consider Twitter networks to be a
form of a disease this is a map of a
polio epidemic going through Nigeria so
a lot of us were raised thinking that
polio was eradicated it was eradicated
here but it still thrives in some parts
of the world and so the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation for global good
stationed over on the east side here in
Siena in Bellevue puts a lot of
resources into a mob
in controlling disease such as polio and
malaria and now Ebola okay
so that's another great example of a
time varying dynamical system that could
be described as a PDE it could be
described as a high dimensional OD e we
could solve it using analytic techniques
or numerical techniques okay so this is
just kind of the the very very rapid
overview of some of the applications
that I have in mind when talking about
this material I want you to be able to
bring what you find interesting to class
if you have a topic that you find you
know great and interesting we can build
our problems around that that's that's
great that would be ideal okay any
questions about any of this stuff
no no so I mean control systems are
pretty straightforward once you have a
good foundation and ODU's so we'll think
about you know analyzing OD es that are
being controlled but you don't have to
know anything about control design yeah
you don't have to know about fluid
dynamics or disease modeling or climate
or weather or any of that we're going to
start from scratch and we're going to
build everything up okay
okay good a what time is it okay so it's
10:00 a.m. I'm going to finish a little
bit early today because I want you know
to have some time if anyone has
questions after class so I'll just do
one quick example before let's see I'll
do one quick example before we go
okay good good okay so one of the themes
that we're going to be talking about
when we build Oh des we're going to
start really really simple without use
but what I want to emphasize is that
systems of equations that we deal with
in real systems get big very very fast
okay so all of the systems that we're
interested in probably will scale up to
very very large systems of equations
pretty rapidly okay I'm going to start
with a toy example to try to illustrate
this idea okay
so we all know that there's three types
of weather in Seattle right it can be
rainy cloudy or nice okay today it
happens to be rainy so if it's rainy
then tomorrow there's a 50% chance that
it will still be rainy if it's cloudy
there's a 50% chance that tomorrow it
will still be cloudy if it's nice today
it probably won't be nice tomorrow but
it could be rainy or cloudy and I'm
going to say that if it's nice it could
be 50% rainy tomorrow and 50% cloudy
tomorrow and maybe there's only a 25%
chance that if it's cloudy or rainy
today that it'll be nice tomorrow okay
so there's a couple of branches missing
okay if it's cloudy today or rainy today
then it could be 25% chance that
tomorrow it'll be the other one okay
pretty simple this is just a toy model
what the weather is going to be like in
Seattle from day to day today okay and
so what we can write down first of all
we're going to represent this as a
vector so we're going to say that our
weather today is rainy okay so rainy
nice cloudy so our vector represents the
probability of what the weather is today
so the weather is definitely rainy today
under percent probability okay
and we're going to say that the weather
tomorrow the probability of the weather
tomorrow is going to equal some a matrix
times the probability of what the
weather is today okay
pretty simple this is a very crude model
for the weather and so we can write down
this a matrix we can say okay well a is
0.5 0.5 0.25 okay so this is the
probability that it's rainy today nice
today or cloudy today and the rows are
going to be the probability that it's
rainy tomorrow nice tomorrow or cloudy
tomorrow okay so the rest of this matrix
we can just read off of this chart so if
it is rainy today nice tomorrow there's
a 25% chance 0 0.25 0.25 0.5 0.5 okay we
just built a model okay this is a
mathematical model to describe the
probability of the weather in time I
mean I made all these numbers up you
could collect these from data and
actually figure out what the real
statistics are wouldn't be too difficult
okay
and so the way they were going to use
this model this is essentially a form of
a differential equation or it's a
difference equation it's a little more
general okay so I have the weather today
x1 this is a you know it's rainy and I
can get the weather tomorrow by
multiplying this vector by this matrix
okay x2 is a times X 1 that will give me
the probability of the weather tomorrow
so what is a times x-1 it's just 0.5
point two five point two five so
unfortunately there's a 50% chance it'll
be rainy tomorrow and 25% chance that it
might be nice or it might be cloudy okay
and you can keep going x3 you just
multiply it by another a you multiply x2
by a and you get the weather on day
three and you can keep going okay and
this is a basic weather model okay this
will tell you how the weather changes in
time based on what it is today this
isn't the best model this is pretty
crude but this is you know we're using
vectors and matrices to represent a
dynamical system of the weather okay
we're going to code this up in a couple
minutes
any questions about this setup okay
now you could imagine that you so this
system has three states right it has the
probability that it's rainy nice or
cloudy right now in Seattle but you
could imagine making this much more
complicated all right so we have a globe
and I can't really draw but let's say
that's that's terrible that's America
and you could break this globe up into
one kilometer boxes across the entire
globe and you could also say let's say
that the state is not just rainy nicer
cloudy but it's also a temperature and
humidity and pressure wind direction and
speed okay and so immediately our
three-dimensional model becomes a
millions or billions of dimensional
model describing the weather on the
entire globe okay you could represent it
as this kind of a probability transition
Markov model in fact that's what people
did for a really long time until they
came up with better models so this is
just a quick example of how systems get
really really big really really fast
okay this model could equally well be
whether or not I am infected with Ebola
I'm in recovery from Ebola
and I have never had a ball and like you
know not infected and there could be
some probability that I could get
infected if I'm not or that I might be
in recovery I guess you'd have another
box here which would be that you're dead
and you can imagine that that four state
system there's one of those for every
single person on planet earth okay so
now we have a 24 or 28 billion
dimensional ordinary differential
equation describing how disease might
propagate through the entire planet but
fortunately that big a matrix has almost
entirely zeros because I don't go to
Africa or China or India on a daily
basis so I come in contact with about a
thousand people every day so my row is
only going to have about a thousand
nonzero elements okay just an example of
how systems get really really really big
really fast for systems that we actually
care about so there are people right now
modeling the spread of Ebola using
gigantic matrices with mostly zeros okay
okay so let's code this up and do a
quick simulation and then we'll end for
the day okay okay so I want to make this
class kind of have a pretty solid MATLAB
component but we're going to build
everything up from scratch and hopefully
those of you who are not super familiar
with MATLAB will just will be picking
this up okay let's see
laptop projector local
great okay
okay so we're in MATLAB again so I
actually do recommend you buy this
product but there are things you can
download on the Internet
okay so we're going to make a quick
strip script to analyze the system okay
we're going to clear all we're going to
create our big matrix a that gives us
our transition probabilities so a was
0.5 0.5 0.25 that's one row then 0.25 Oh
0.25 that's another row and then 0.25
0.5 0.5 that's the final row so this
remember gives me the probability of the
weather tomorrow given the weather today
so let's say X today equals 1 0-0
today is rainy right
today was a rainy day but we want to
know what the weather is going to be
like tomorrow so we're going to say for
I equals 1 to 10 let's say we want to
know the 10 day forecast we're going to
say X tomorrow is equal to a times X
today and at the end of every day
tomorrow becomes today yeah or today
becomes tomorrow super simple ok I have
a vector representing my probability
today this is a column vector so these
semicolons mean that it's arranged as
the column vector I have my a matrix
that tells me what my weather will be
like tomorrow given my weather today and
I'm going to cycle through ten days and
compute what the probability of the
weather is on day to date day 1 day 2
day 3 day 4 up to day 10 from now okay
so if i run this save this as weather I
get all of my maybe I'll just say what
day it is so day I
okay so tomorrow 50% chance of rain 25%
chance cloudy and nice or nice and
cloudy then 43 percent 44 percent chance
of rain on day 2 20% chance nice
40% chance cloudy ok and notice it's
starting to kind of converge and by day
6 were pretty much at a steady state
weather distribution okay so in the near
future maybe a week out using a crude
model like this even if it was nice
today or cloudy today you would have no
certainty aside from these probability
distributions of what the weather's
going to be like in a few days and five
or six days okay so old weather models
have very short forecast times largely
because they were built on these
probabilistic models okay we can always
plot this in MATLAB we can let's see you
can plot well I didn't save any of the
data will do plotting later okay okay
are there any questions about this
simple example okay so on Friday we're
going to hit the ground running with
ordinary differential equations we're
going to start with X dot equals a times
X X dot equals a times X just a
one-dimensional linear first-order
equation if you don't feel comfortable
with calculus I want you to review that
between now and then so the power law
chain rule Taylor series we're going to
be using Taylor series a ton it's the
most powerful tool in calculus that's
what we're going to do on Friday okay
thank you
you
you